foreign
d
everybody understands what's happening
not far from here and uh you know i
think the
uh what this brings to light is the fact
that the nato alliance is rock solid and
uh we've never had a doubt of that but
it's coming together
together to train in a very real way to
be able to fire a live munition in a
kinetic way with air force with cyber
with
electronic warfare with artillery
i i think everybody feels that what
we're doing is is very important at this
time what we experienced in iraq and
afghanistan
was the tailoring of a force to the
threat that we faced at that time and
clearly as we look at what's happening
to our east we see artillery on both
sides of the russia ukraine conflict
playing a pivotal role so all the more
important now that we take this exercise
that we've been doing for years and grow
it to a point that we
are technically and tactically
compatible with one another that we're
personally and professionally compatible
with one another and that we achieve
that interoperability amongst the
different members of the alliance and
our partners here in theaters